[Music]
Bernardo Arevalo let a landslide
electoral victory in Guatemala's
national election and from Civil Society
groups to private sector leaders the
sentiment shared by many appears to be
one of optimism
of course everybody has concerns and I
guess he will have concerns too it's
part of being in a in a in a political
situation but my concerns are more on
the weight of of those things that maybe
we can think different
a but I certainly be Optimist that the
common things that we have will go
further instead of that points that
maybe we can have as a differences
political analysts say is that many in
the country see him as a political
Centrist who has placed the fight
against corruption at the top of his
presidential agenda once in office
the wake of the national election many
Guatemalans say they feel confident
Bernardo arevalo's leadership will bring
about much needed change for some
experts however that feeling is more a
sense of cautious optimism
though the election may be over some
argue that certifying the results could
become Complicated by legal objections
from arevalo's opponents
according to political columnist
Carolina Escobar the government of
Guatemala's president-elect could be
undermined by the Attorney General's
office which has made repeated attempts
to suspend arevalo's semiya party over
allegations of fraud
this system that has been used has
allowed certain actors to gain a lot of
power and use the law shamelessly to go
after individuals who have no
responsibility in criminal acts it is
used to Target people politically
because in this country persecutions are
political
experts in Guatemala say that arrests
could be made against members of
arevalo's semiya party and many expect
there will be continued actions that
seek to prevent Arevalo from being sworn
in next January Manuel rapalo Al Jazeera
Guatemala City